My mom is 84 years old and she's at home watching.
Mom, I just won an Oscar.
My journey started on a boat.
I spent a year in a refugee camp...
...and somehow I ended up here on Hollywood's biggest stage.
They say stories like this only happen in the movies.
I cannot believe it's happening to me.
This is the American Dream.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much to the Academy for this honor of a lifetime.
Thank you to my mom for the sacrifice that she made to get me here.
To my little brother David, who calls me every day,...
...just to remind me to take good care of myself.
I love you, brother.
I owe everything to the love of my life, my wife Echo,...
...who, month after month, year after year, for 20 years,...
...told me that one day my time will come.
Dreams are something you have to believe in.
I almost gave up on mine.
To all of you out there, please keep your dreams alive.